if a film is not entertaining forget it
it's a failure I am unashamedly in the
entertainment business and I mean I
would make that statement on two levels
on the primary level I would say if a
film or any piece of work doesn't
entertain it fails in and to using the
word entertain literally meaning it it
holds you there and you become absorbed
by it so that you don't walk away and
get bored but over and above that I mean
I you know sure I make films that are
about real life sure they are realistic
and I go to great lengths to achieve
that sure they resonate with people's
real experiences sure their emotional
sure they're properly psychologically
motivated sure the characters are rooted
in society you know you absolutely can
recognize and know that this we're
dealing with the substance of the real
world in terms of the texture of the
thing but at the same time my films are
funny they are heightened there are all
kinds there are all kinds of
juxtapositions which are not simply life
unda stilled as its hewn from the same
and you know what at the most basic
level are my influences
look thing is again you know I'm hurting
to to proclaim about what entertainment
should or shouldn't do you know you talk
about reality shows and all of that
which are basically if you think about
it just simply modern equivalent to
Victorian freak shows where people with
you know anomalous growths and things
and you know ladies with beards and
whatever it was people with three feet
no would be put on exhibition for the
public you know there have always been
and there always will be a peripheral
sideline activities which are a form of
entertainment which to say you know you
pay a couple of cents and you see
something freakish well that's what
reality TV is and I don't think with all
due respects that really belongs in the
conversation that we're having because
what we're actually talking about is art
we're talking about you know work but in
some way however it does it wants to get
to some kind of truth and therefore have
something substantial to offer an
audience so you know entertainment is an
essential you know that I think be
entertaining is an essential ingredient
as I've said and I think we shouldn't we
should dismiss and tolerate and in fact
keep our sense of humor about peripheral
crackpot activities because they don't
really come into the job of the proper
artist or the job of the committed
audience which you said the audience
that really wants to be stimulated
you